(thumping)
(upbeat rock music)
- It is now time for
tonight's Hashtag Wars.
(audience cheers)
Kerry Kenney.
- I thought my son's saxophone
recital was too short.
(audience laughs)
(ding)
- Nick.
- If you spend more
money on Fruit Loops
than you do on rent.
(laughs)
- Points.
(ding)
Marlon.
- I've been watching a
Honey Boo Boo marathon.
That bitch is deep.
(laughs)
(ding)
- Kerry.
- My mom's 40 minute story
about her cat was fascinating.
- Points.
(ding)
Nick.
- If you though Avatar
was a documentary.
(laughs)
(ding)
- Points.
Marlon.
- My fingers taste like chicken
but my thumb tastes
like (bleep).
(audience cheers)
- Points.
(ding)
I wish we had more time to
get the details of that story.
(electronic tones)
Rob Huebel.
- Kale-Ifornication.
- Yes, points.
(ding)
Lennon.
- The Walking,
Not Driving, Dead.
- Points.
(ding)
Huebel.
- Commune-ity.
- Uh.
- Hey, come on.
Come on!
Fine, take them all
away, take 'em all away.
- [Chris] I'm not gonna
take all your points away.
- I don't care, wipe 'em clean.
- [Chris] You're gonna care if
I take all your points away.
- Please don't take 'em away.
- OK, I will not take 'em away.
(ding)
Lennon.
- Just the 10-Prius.
- Oh, Just the 10
of Us, yes, points.
That's an old
demographic, yes yes yes.
(ding)
Rob Huebel.
- CSI Think We Can
Recycle This, guys.
- Yes, points.
(electronic tones)
Brandon.
- Yo Mama Mia.
(ding)
- Points.
Paul Scheer.
- Annie Get Your Gat.
- Points.
Andy Daly.
- Mary Popp-in a cap
in a mother (bleep)
- Points, for sure.
Yes, Paul Scheer.
- The Scissor-up King.
- Points.
(ding)
Yes, TV's Andy Daly.
- How To Succeed in Business
by Executing Biggie Smalls.
- Whoa, the look of
shock on your own face.
(ding)
Brandon.
- Yeezus Christ Superstar.
- Points.
Andy Daly.
- Long Day's Journey
into Sug-night.
- You're very focused
on that case, points.
(ding)
Brandon Johnson.
- Best Little
Whorehouse in Compton.
(buzzer)
- Yes.
(electronic tones)
Steve.
- Annual Office Colonoscopy Day.
(audience boos)
- Yes, points.
April.
- Bring Your Teenage Daughter's
Daughter to Work Day.
- Points.
- Sensitivity Training Bra Day.
- What is that?
- What are we, like a
rock concert in here?
- I'll give you points, I
don't know what it means,
but I'll give you points.
Tom.
- Bring Your Grandma
to Twerk Day.
- Points.
Oh man, Tom Lennon came to play.
April.
- Take Your Secretary
to Hooters Day.
- Yeah, that would be
not a good one, points.
Steve.
- Shut the (bleep)
up about your kids
for one (bleep)ing day, Linda.
(buzzer)
- [Chris] Yes, points.
(upbeat rock music)